millions of holiday packages are being  processed at a unique facility here in  the valley the usps has what's called a  parcel support annex in henderson home  to special sorting machines that run 24  hours a day helping sort even more  packages before but the agency says it  still takes a team of real people to  make it happen  we have uh folks unloading and loading  trucks we also have um employees that  are sorting manually for some of the  parcels as well so they're they're  utilized everywhere in the operation  2020 was a record year but this year  could see more packages coming through  usps says just last week more than 2  million were sorted locally next week  expected to be the heaviest week for  shipping centers